yes very good good morning fiery it is
Monday now I didn't post a Friday over
last week because I was helping launch
the hashtag thanks mom campaign which
was really fun thank you guys for
participating I hope your moms like gifs
that you made for them so here's a quick
look back at some of the fiery clips
from last week just like I requested
Brianna hello
it is Sunday how was your Sunday oh
that's very amazing for you and now we
were headed to shoot with Nicki lemo I'm
very excited she just texted asking me
if I wanted a Moscow Mule
so already best collaboration it's
currently Monday and now I'm headed to
the graced show house because we're
shooting an episode tomorrow with James
Corden and Lance Bass which I'm so
excited about because James Corden
love's boy bands we're doing a lot of
boy bands centric things for this week's
episode after we go over some creative
I'm gonna go do @midnight
[Music]
yeah bugles upgrade hi
guys get back from running and you're
sleeping up there this we like this
sleep we're getting ready to start
shooting promos look at this ensemble eh
yeah overall look at this crew so pumped
dressing for a funeral is really on
trend you guys we just wrapped the
episode Lance was amazing periscope
no no not periscoping filming just
straight-up filming um did you have fun
I had a blast like rotten milk right now
yeah I mean it's all for good but I'm
Phil look at this sweatshirt by the way
where did you get this from I have no
idea I think I stole it from my husband
hey now I can't ever wear it again
because I worked on the grace Helbig
show Hey and the gifs will just be all
over the place gif whatever who knows
yeah terrible things transpired there
[Music]
Wow first of all before you get into the
week I have to tell you guys that Hannah
Hart mamrie Hart and I are going on tour
again for the no filter show in honor of
memories book that comes out you guys
know this by now or you should so buy
your tickets for the shows all the links
are down below today we're gonna go
shoot two field pieces for the grace
Helbig show one with the foster sisters
who have this pseudo reality show on vh1
about them trying to be celebrities and
famous and they're really really cool so
we're shooting peace with them and then
we're shooting peace with superfruit
with Mitch and Scott from pentatonix and
they have prepared some music I believe
and I'm so excited we're getting a - ooh
a field piece with the foster sisters
and Justin's here hey Jessa use damit
damit available for presale look at this
dress is showing and telling today in
this dark abandoned kitchen scary when
the lights aren't on the people are here
with the foster sister Erin & Sarah
where you shot a segment for the show
and it was hilarious they're really
hilarious at social media advice so
highly recommend going and following
them
yeah and checking out because the is the
whole season online right now Hulu on
Hulu barely famous on vh1 on demand and
on Hulu go check it out yeah hello and
happy Tuesday to everyone it is another
gray day in lausanne
I'm headed to the great show house yeah
to go over creative for the show this
week or no not this week here's the news
guys the news um you'll probably have
heard about this by Friday but if you
don't know the last two episodes of the
first season of the race comic show are
moving to Sunday's episode that would be
airing this Friday is now airing and
then the last to oppose will be on
Sunday nights which I'm so excited about
I think it'll be easier for you guys to
watch and you now have a Friday night
that you can go out I give you full
permission to if you want or you can
stay in and just long for the days that
the grace Helbig show was on Friday
nights so Sunday May 31st this next
episode that we're shooting is going to
have Adam Devine from workaholics and
pitch perfect 2 and Jack Black and I'm
so excited because I've I've met Adam
before and he's extremely nice and very
very funny and I've heard really great
things about Jack Black so my
expectations for interacting with nice
humans are high then oh I did enjoy you
this then the craziest thing is that I
have a text message from Nikki Lima over
the weekend oh we showed a video
together if you haven't seen that link
is down below I got a text message from
licking licking Nemo telling me that
nah-ha the psychic that was on the last
episode of the grace Helbig show it's
her psychic she's been going to for
years and she's awesome and she had
already had an appointment to see her
today she only sees her twice a year so
weird so I'm gonna tag along with her
and go see Naha today and see what Naha
has to say how weird is that
okay so let's first make some jokes for
Jack Black we're testing on a game we're
gonna play
very confusing and sexual good morning
it's 8 a.m. but the shoot house evidence
it's a shoot day hi guys I'm in New York
City it is currently 2 a.m. yes I will
prove it to you
this 2 a.m.
yeah - OH - I just got off a flight I'm
in New York I haven't explained this for
the NBCUniversal up front he is under
the whole NBCUniversal umbrella and so
up fronts are basically a way for their
people to go talk to advertisers to get
them to like me and just spend money on
me and to make commercials happen during
my show something I'm very good at is
talking to people and getting them to
spend money on me so at 11:00 a.m. I get
hair makeup done and then we go over to
the up front don't know what's gonna
happen there exactly and then Friday I
go and I do the commencement speech at
Ramapo College the college that I went
to which is so exciting and my parents
are coming I'm really like so pumped I
watt while I'll be really pumped once I
write the speech yeah
also wearing overalls because yeah
this is advertisers spend money on me
choose me
Real Housewives of Orange County are
coming behind me
hi guys I'm back two girls that means
I'm done just got back from the
NBCUniversal up front it was intense I
think there's probably a lot of like
photos made like not sure what's
happening but I saw a lot of Real
Housewives which was great I met Terry
Dubrow
who is Heather Dubrow husband and he is
one of the plastic surgeons on botched
and he was so nice and I saw Kim Zolciak
her butt is so beautiful in person very
inspirational in person so now I'm going
to write my speech for the commencement
tomorrow and order some food and take
this dress off and put clothes on human
clothes
[Music]
[Applause]
we did it I gave a commencement speech
at the college that I graduated from and
I think it went okay I feel good about
it it's currently 236 a.m. I have choo
getting a cargo airport at 6:45 a.m.
from the college graduates that's four
hours thanks for watching for a diary
don't forget to go buy your tickets for
a no filter show tour things back
tacular with head on remember especially
if you're in Chicago that's the first
place that we are going to and tickets
are almost sold out
and last time went to Chicago it was so
insanely fun and the Vic theater that
we're performing at it's just a
beautiful theater so please make sure
that you buy your tickets ASAP the link
is
[Music]
[Music]